no no she didn't ghost me she just
doesn't have an international calling
plan oh right I'm pretty sure I have
been ghosted
I don't remember maybe I just decided to
forget I feel like I've had something
much worse where at least if you're
ghosted you can tell yourself a lie I'm
like oh maybe they you know lost my
number or something but but I've had the
the
gradual less and less and less text to
the point where you're like okay I guess
it depends on what proceeded was there a
really nice date if you had a really
good date and the other person is under
the impression that this is going to
continue and then that's it for that's
the problem the expectations are you on
the same page do you think this is just
one date and let's have fun and that's
it or what make you think that we're
gonna see each other no Disappearing
Acts for honest plus one Tinder
executive Paul bukadakis they started
dating after her split from Ben Affleck
in 2021 the same year Chris began
secretly seeing his girlfriend actress
Alba Baptista ghosting is just so harsh
isn't it Chris and anastarian and
produced ghosted out Friday on Apple TV
plus Chris plays the guy who falls for
the girl travels to make a grand
romantic gesture then find out she's
actually a secret agent
you got me kidnapped and tortured all
after one day
I loved every moment of you know
watching him trip and stumble and roll
down the hill and all of that swallowing
rocks and it was really cool I I did
love the dynamic I loved the the you
know the reversing the roles and the
expectations of what an action movie
should be like and who carries a film in
the sense of that you know the strength
and being in control it's it's nice to
play someone who has far less
capabilities than someone like Captain
America but but in moments of panic has
a very human reaction nothing about coal
is cool you know he he goes he goes to
Pieces um but it's endearing
you you have the wrong guy I'm a former
wait wait
this is the pair's third film together
after Knives Out And The Gray Man and
with that black dress and these action
scenes it's giving major Mr and Mrs
Smith Vibes you are unbelievable what
what it was a lot of work action movies
are very demanding painful but the
problem is honestly since the bar too
high on the first day of filming she
does things so well and it's like well
now you're screwed because they're gonna
basically say oh she can do it we're
gonna have her do everything we don't
even need this level I mean like on at
the cave sequence was the first chunk of
filming we had and I remember the first
time I saw her do this sequence and
flipping a guy over her head and I was
like oh my God someone's been doing
their stunt training Jesus well the
thing is I have to train and work for it
he just showed up
and another Duty that comes just as easy
being the sexiest man alive so many
things yeah now I just like I get it I
always knew it but now everyone else
does too so it just feels right you can
throw Paul Bettany in there or Aaron
Taylor I mean come on
foreign